LEON ZHAO: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
OK.
It's show time.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
Please give a self
introduction for yourself,
and then we'll go
through the slides.
KOH KIM: My name is Koh Kim.
I'm part of the Google Play
Games business development team
in Mountain View, California.
I cover the United States and
a lot of our Western markets
and work with games startups
from all over the world.
YOSHI: My name is Yoshi.
I'm working for Google Play apps
and games for the Japan market,
so I'm based in
Tokyo and consulting
the Japanese developers, as
well as the [INAUDIBLE] who want
to enter the Japanese market.
KH: My name is KH.
I'm based in Seoul, Korea.
I'm working for [INAUDIBLE]
games business in Korea.
So I'm helping import and
export process for all contents
and then helping our
overall ecosystem better.
KEVIN: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
LEON ZHAO: Thanks
for the introduction.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
Let's start with the slides.
So Koh.
KOH KIM: So I'm going to talk a
little bit about the US market,
and then after this, Europe.
And so this is just
an example of some
of the more popular games.
Actually, games and applications
that are in the United States.
You may recognize the "Clash
of Clans," "Candy Crush Saga."
But it's just to note
that there's actually
a very diverse range
of game genres that
are very popular in the US,
ranging from the casual Match 3
Puzzle Games all the
way to the City Builder
simulation and strategy
games that you often would
[INAUDIBLE].
But actually, another one of
our popular-- casino games
are popular.
We also have drawn
representations
from many developers
from all over the world.
Not just from Europe,
but also from Japan
and the rest of Asia, as well.
And also, applications
are very popular.
And so Pandora's one example.
People in the United States,
they love their music.
They love their social and
communication applications.
The engagement is really high
in applications like that,
and so there's a lot of
opportunity to find success
in the US market.
Just as I said, for
games, diverse genres.
Some of the other things that
have been very interesting
is that there's a lot
of multiplayer games.
Before it's been
mostly asynchronous,
single player games.
But now, with better
infrastructure and broadband
networks, you're seeing a lot
more synchronous or real time
multiplayer games.
And so a lot of the
games that are actually
popular in this country, such
as action RPGs and all of that
are actually slowly making their
way into the United States.
Some of the other stuff
we wanted to talk about
is non-games-- so just regular
applications, as I said.
Communication, social
applications are very popular.
There's probably a new
picture taking, photo taking,
video taking application
that shows up every week.
There's a lot of high
engagement in that front.
And there's also a really
big growth of, I would say,
mobile, social
commerce, as well.
A lot of friends,
a lot of people
are recommending what
types of things to buy
and what types of products to
buy via these social networks.
And so that's been very
interesting to take a look at.
In terms of payments,
credit cards
are very ubiquitous
in the United States.
People are not afraid
to use credit cards
for digital payments.
But there's also a wide usage
of carrier billing, and also
gift cards, as well.
But definitely, credit cards is
the predominant payment method.
So let's talk a little
bit about Europe.
Europe is very similar
to the United States.
Pretty diverse range.
But there's a couple
of differences.
There's a lot more hard core
strategy games that are seen,
mostly of the Western fantasy.
So you think of the knights,
the dragons, the King Arthur,
Camelot.
A lot of that mythology, you
will see as themes in games.
"Empire Four Kingdoms" is
an example of that-- a lot
of medieval themes that
occurs in those games.
But then you see a lot
of other games too.
You see Top Eleven, which
is a top soccer game there.
And so they actually really
like their sports simulation
and football manager
games in Europe.
And so that's also something
to take note of, as well.
And start talking a little
bit about market trends.
If I'm talking too
fast, let me know.
I'm trying to get
through a lot of this.
LEON ZHAO: If the translator
is OK, then that'll be fine.
KOH KIM: OK.
But let me know if
I'm talking too fast.
For a lot of games, as
I said, very similar
to the United States.
Certain sports games do become
a lot more popular, especially
soccer.
It's religion there, so
a lot of soccer games
are very popular there.
And also, if you look at
the application store,
it's very similar tastes.
But it's not the US version
of those applications
that are popular.
There's actually local
versions of, let's say,
the social networks, or some
of the photo taking apps,
and the Instagrams
and all that stuff.
And even music
apps, as well, they
tend to be like very local.
A lot of the more
popular music apps
such as Spotify and
SoundCloud have actually
been created in Europe.
In terms of payments,
there are some differences.
Versus credit cards,
actually, there's
a lot more prepaid gift
cards and Paypal usage
that's occurred in Europe.
But that's just a matter
of consumer preference.
LEON ZHAO: Yoshi?
YOSHI: So I would
like to explain
about the Japanese market.
So this is the top ranking
of the last week in Japan.
So compared with the US
and the European's ranking
is totally different.
Probably in here the atendee
is familiar a little bit
with the characters.
And of course, the [INAUDIBLE]
is a pretty long life.
And they make it in a good
business end Japan market.
And also, those
titles are all almost
from the Japanese market,
Japanese developers.
And a recent trend of the
Japanese game industry
is that much players is
super trending right now.
So first of all, they're
most of it's making
the much players,
cultures, bringing
into the smartphone in Japan.
Then many game developers
are following those trends
right now in the Japan market.
And also, the Japanese
market is quite
different compare with
the other markets which
is that users prefer to play
in the co-op or much player
and not fight each other.
It's more like corporations,
and much player,
and [INAUDIBLE] are
making a [? boss ?]
or making it clear as a stage.
That's the trend of
the Japanese market.
Also, generally, in
the Japan market,
the localization is mandatory
to get into the Japan market.
So once the user
who lives in Japan
recognizes that this is
from the outside of Japan,
or the culture is
for the Japan market,
then the user will leave.
So I recommend if you want
to come to the Japan market,
their localization is
the most important thing
to get into the Japan market.
And the game system,
it's pretty complicated.
But the casual games,
plus gacha system,
plus merge evolution grows.
It's pretty popular in
Japan, and the live operation
is important too.
So in terms of the
live operations,
so many live operations
[INAUDIBLE] in the one game,
like 20 live operations in the
one game in [? Delhi. ?] That's
your usual in the Japan market.
So live operation is quite
difficult to operate.
But that's making the
user retention go up.
That's your things.
And the non-games
side, the subscription
shown business model is
pretty popular in Japan,
because the Japanese
users are pretty
familiar with payment pay
[? date ?] mobile contents,
since the feature
phone mobile contents,
which is [INAUDIBLE]
system was in there.
And also, the users only
choice is subscription.
Then the user moves
to the smart phone.
Then they're
familiar with payment
to the digital contents
with subscription.
That's your trend right now.
And also, the
education and shopping
is getting popular on
the smartphone, as well.
That's pretty similar with
the US market, I guess.
And then payment system,
that I direct carrier billing
and a Google Play gift
card, all payment system
is available in Japan.
But a Japanese user is
allowed to pay the money
on direct [INAUDIBLE] billing.
LEON ZHAO: KH?
So it's actually easy
to remember KH's name,
because he's responsible
for for Korea.
KH: So actually, the
screen that you're seeing,
we announced the best
application and games of 2014
last week.
And then those are
our best game titles
and applications of 2014.
For the Korean market,
actually, the last year,
we saw a huge growth
with social games.
There are many positive games.
But this year, we saw that the
market changed very quickly.
So the most popular genre
is action RPG or MMORPG.
So you can see that
[INAUDIBLE], for example, there
are some very popular
RPG titles in the chart.
And then for sure,
"Clash of Clan,"
they're working
very well in Korea.
So actually, they have been the
number one placement of our top
[INAUDIBLE] for awhile.
The next slide please?
LEON ZHAO: Sure.
KH: So the hardcore action
RPG are very popular.
And then for those
game developers,
their common marketing strategy
is to have preregistrations.
So that's a common activity.
And also, the one unique
fact for a Korean market
is when you think of entering
the Korean market you need
to have a lot of content,
because Korean users,
they're very aggressive.
They consume every
content in a week,
so you need to
think of preparing
enough content for the titles.
And for sure, going
global initiative
is the main agenda
for Korean developers.
For non-game side, the
O2O service is very hot.
So for example, food
delivery service
is very competitive in Korea.
So many companies are
thinking of connecting offline
to mobile-- that is, mainstream.
And also, for Uber,
there's Uber in Korea.
But also, there are other
Uber-like services emerging.
So that kind of O2O is
very important in Korea.
Also, because we have
a very high ratio
of high penetration
of credit cards,
the m-commerce is
soaring in Korea too.
Other than that, the
lifestyle utility applications
is getting more
popular and popular.
For payment, we just launched
Google Gift Card last month
and with that, direct carrier
billing and credit card.
Those three are the
main forms of payment
for the Korean market.
LEON ZHAO: OK, Kevin?
KEVIN: So I took this
screenshot last week,
and I think it's just
games, not apps and games.
So I apologize for
anyone who's in apps.
But the only difference between
this chart and the apps chart
is that it's just one
app, and that's Line.
So there are no other
apps in the top grossing,
I don't think other than that.
The top 100 grossing
apps and games in Taiwan,
there's only one app,
and that is Line.
And so if you look
here, Taiwan's
a very interesting market.
Notibably missing from this
list is a lot of Western titles.
"Candy Crush" is the
only Western title.
There's no "Clash of Clans."
There's no "Machine Zone."
There's none of these
bigger, Western devs
that have gone
global to Taiwan yet.
Next slide?
So unlike Japan and Korea
though, there's no incumbent.
There hasn't been a
number one grosser
that stays in that spot,
whereas in other markets
around the world,
you might actually
see-- GungHo and Mixi don't
really move that much.
And they might switch
between one and two.
But they've been number
one for weeks, or maybe
more than that-- maybe months.
And in Taiwan, that
chart, if you go back
one slide, the 1 through
5-- actually, 1 through 7
have all switched spots
pretty much every week.
So based on their
event schedule,
when I took this, "LINE Rangers"
just did a major event--
big sale, live operations.
But before this,
they were number 10.
So they went to number 10 to
number 2 when they do an event,
and then they drop
back to 10 after this.
So if you look at it
right now, they're
probably not even top 10.
So if you go back
to the next slide--
so the interesting thing
is that Taiwan is now
a top five global revenue
market for Google Play.
There's been an increase of
25% of Chinese-- [CHINESE]--
mainland Chinese developers
and top grossing since
the beginning of
this year alone.
So a lot more of the
Chinese developers
are now coming to Taiwan
whereas before, it was mostly
Taiwanese developers or
Taiwanese publishers,
and Japan and Korea in content.
So as you can tell,
Japan and Korea,
the content is very prevalent.
But a lot of times, the
monetization model in Taiwan
is a lot different.
One of the things I've
noticed as a consumer,
playing a lot of Chinese
games, is basically,
I might play the Japanese
version of the game.
And then I play the Taiwanese
version of the same game.
And the monetization model,
if they don't change it,
it doesn't do that well in
terms of top grossing charts.
The game is still fun.
But I think it's a lot because
of the gacha system in Japan.
If I spend a lot of
money to buy something,
I expect to get something
worth that value.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
That's very normal in
Japan, where you might just
do gacha over and over,
and you never win anything.
And they'll keep spending.
But in Chinese, I feel
like if we spend $100,
we expect to get an item.
LEON ZHAO: So the Chinese
don't believe in luck?
KEVIN: It's just
one of those things
that you always want to keep in
mind of the monetization model
too.
Also, competition is very
fierce between people,
whereas Yoshi just
said, everybody
wants to work together in Japan.
And Taiwan and Hong
Kong games, or at least
in Chinese developer
games, I notice that it's
all about competition.
I want to be the best.
I don't want to work together.
So it's also interesting to
note that Taiwanese people spend
most of the time on
their mobile devices
than anywhere else in the world.
That's 200 minutes a day.
That's more than three hours
a day on their mobile device.
That's pretty crazy,
and you'll notice it.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
So still lots of policy
violations though.
Dana just had her talk,
so this is good timing.
IP infringement is very common.
I spend a good part of my week
taking down apps and games that
are IP infringement.
Sexual content, also
very popular in the sense
that they do it, and
then we block them.
And then spam
installs [CHINESE].
This will get you in a lot of
trouble with our policy team.
We can track this.
And then third party
payments, [CHINESE],
still very popular in
Taiwan in the sense
that people try to use
them on Google Play.
But you know this is a
policy violation, as well.
And then in terms of
marketing, there's
a lot of offline marketing too.
Every taxi is covered in a game.
Every TV inside the
taxi has a game.
Every bus has a game on it.
Every subway station
has a game on it.
Even the buildings
are covered in games.
And then in turn of
non-games though, they're
still very, very popular.
The one that's
noticeably missing,
I have social lifestyle
chat, news, music, and video.
Commerce is starting
to change a lot now.
All the big sites in
Taiwan, like PCHome, 17Life,
[INAUDIBLE] Life, all
these kind of apps--
they're all making very, very
strong material design apps.
So you can do a lot of
browsing, because they shared
with me that I think
something like over 40%
of their interactions, they
all happen on mobile compared
to web, whereas only a year ago
in Taiwan, people didn't use
their phones as much; mostly
because 3G became much more
widespread in the last year.
In terms of payments, I
know this has been an issue.
You guys asked Brahim about
it earlier this morning.
Credit card's
still very popular.
DCB launched in
May of this year.
And we have people working
on that the gift cards,
but we have to
understand that it's not
as easy as just launching.
LEON ZHAO: [CHINESE],
TPP, third party payment.
[CHINESE], direct card billing.
So you should know
TPP more DCB, right?
[CHINESE], Google
Play presentation.
Hong Kong?
KEVIN: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
They're all games here.
Interestingly enough,
"Supercell's" not in this
chart either.
Neither is "Machine Zone."
"Candy Crush" isn't even
in this chart.
So not a lot of Western
content in Hong Kong.
As you can see, a lot of
Chinese content though.
Same as Taiwan.
Number one has always changed.
There is no clear winner.
In Taiwan, Hong
Kong, there isn't
somebody that is so
powerful that they're always
number one, whereas in the
other markets, it's like that.
And I think because
Taiwan, Hong Kong are still
emerging markets, we don't
have full payment covers yet.
But it's coming quite quickly.
Taiwan went from--
I think it grew 8x.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
It's like a revenue.
So it's pretty crazy.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
LEON ZHAO: Because
you arrived at Taiwan.
KEVIN: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
But given that HK
is mostly urban,
the average revenue per
paying user is very high.
So when I say mostly
urban [CHINESE]
It's a big city.
There's not a lot of country.
So almost everyone
has a mobile device.
So in terms of non-game
messaging apps, all of them
are very popular.
It's not like Korea, Japan,
or Taiwan where one chat app,
everybody uses.
In Hong Kong, you see a
combination of all the chat
apps that everybody uses,
as well as TV and streaming
content is very, very popular.
And we do have credit
cards, gift cards,
and carrier billing.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
LEON ZHAO: So we're going
to go to the panel session.
But we don't have
a lot of time left.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
So I'm going to skip this one.
So you are the [? BD ?]
person locally,
and you work with a
lot of the developers.
And you help a lot
of them to go global.
So what are some of the
best practices from them,
with some specific
examples if you have,
I can share with the
Chinese people over here?
KOH KIM: Sure.
So first impressions count.
If you think about how your
user or potential customer
player will get to
your application,
eventually, they'll have to
go to the Google Play Store.
And so really thinking
about your visual assets
on the store listing.
This includes creating a really
good icon that is actually
a fit with that market.
If you've noticed, the
icons in the United States
and in Western Europe are
very different than in a lot
of your Asian countries too.
It's probably a lot
more female characters
used in Asian markets
verses in the West.
It's a lot more diverse mix
of characters, and genders,
and all that stuff.
But that's reflective
of the market in itself.
So really thinking
about your icons,
really thinking
about your titles.
Also, video is a
big, big converter.
Within the Western markets, a
lot of users, they watch video.
YouTube is very popular.
And so having a really
good game player trailer
video is really important
when you're trying
to attempt to get in the US.
And then once you get people to
download and install your game,
it's very important to have that
very good day one experience.
If you've noticed,
games in Asia tend
to be probably a little
bit more complicated game
systems, and gameplay
mechanics, and a lot of mix
of different gameplay mechanics
versus what you're going to see
in a lot of Western markets.
This is changing, but it's
very important to have
what I call the first 10
minute gameplay, which
is now, really the first
two minutes of game play
is you want to make sure
you can get your users
and your players into the game
and really understand what they
need to do, and how
to get to the core
gameplay mechanic really
quickly that's fun.
And so the tutorial modes,
on boarding, this stuff
is really, really important.
That's what I probably think is
the biggest difference in terms
of some of the
foreign games I see.
Kevin and some of the
others will talk about some
of the other stuff.
But I think getting
that day one experience
to be nearly flawless is very
important and really worth
your time to think about.
LEON ZHAO: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
So for Yoshi, so
actually currently,
Japan is actually a
big market itself.
But Japanese
developers are still
trying to export games
to the global market.
How did they do it, and what
are the things they did well?
And you can share with
the audience here.
YOSHI: So our two exported
from the Japan market,
it's more like they're trying
to make good translations.
Of course, import to Japans,
go to the Japan market also.
They import to the good
quality translations.
And also, they export
to their contents.
Also, that they're thinking
the translation is important.
And then they are changing
the screenshot, as well.
So in the Japan market, a screen
shot is pretty noisy type.
They're intentionally
making it noisy.
like the anime stuff, and the
many game effects in there.
But go to the Western
market, and they're trying
to less noisy screenshots.
That's your difference
from the Japanese market.
And it depends on the market.
So recently, the trend
of the Japanese market
is in terms of the game, they're
putting the voiceover voice
in the game.
And then sometimes, there are
no translation in those markets,
trying to make it
more like this is
from Japan for popular
in the manga culture.
And then sometimes, they're
changing their voice
to translations,
especially foreign culture
is totally different from the
Japanese culture actually.
That's the things.
LEON ZHAO: So what's
the difference in Korea?
KH: What's the difference?
YOSHI: I don't know.
KH: I wanted to give
an example of Com2uS.
So I talked with the
Com2us people a lot,
and the main key
takeaway is they really
try to understand users
in the local market.
So when they exported
their titles in Taiwan,
actually, the first
thing they did
is to cultivate communities.
So the weird thing, a lot of
hardcore games in Korea too.
But the interesting thing
is the hardcore gamers,
they want to belong
to some communities.
So they want to talk
about the games.
They want to talk about
some events of the games.
They come to us really invested
in cultivating the communities
for their games.
And then the "Ace Fishing"
was the first title
with communities.
And with that, users
in the communities,
they could find success for
some of those other titles.
So understanding the local
users is very important.
And then I can
say that for Korea
too, as we are seeing a lot
of hardcore gamers emerging
in Korea, you need to
think about engaging
with the Korean hardcore
gamers in communities.
KEVIN: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
LEON ZHAO: So first
impression matters.
A screen shot matters.
Community matters,
following the policy better.
So maybe I'll just
ask one more question,
and then we'll take
one live question.
So what do you think
about your market in 2015?
KOH KIM: What will
next year look like?
LEON ZHAO: Yeah.
KOH KIM: Hm.
Hard to say.
LEON ZHAO: That's a tough one.
KEVIN: Taiwan, Hong
Kong, [CHINESE]
2015, you'll notice
that a lot of people
are looking at the same reports.
They look at the report.
They see how much Taiwan
and Hong Kong are growing.
And as they get better
at going global,
you're going to see a lot
more international content,
especially as Google Play,
Brahim just talked about.
As we increase payments
in Taiwan and Hong Kong,
these regions are going
to grow a lot more.
KOH KIM: I think there's
going to be a big rise of what
I call game franchises.
If you look in the console
and entertainment world, some
of the biggest, I would say,
most popular types of content
has always been brands.
There's a reason why Disney,
there's a reason why Blizzard,
there's a reason why
Activision and some
of these other companies--
Activision and Blizzard's
the same.
But if you think
about it, they've
somehow been able to create
these franchises of games
and applications
that's basically
been around for 10 plus years.
And I think mobile gaming
is coming to the fact
that where it's not really
going to be tied to the device.
As we started out
earlier, Android
is now becoming a
ubiquitous platform
across multiple devices.
We're moving towards a more
hardware agnostic world, which
means a lot of this content
has become more immersive,
and will likely come
outside the screen.
And that's where brand is
really going to matter.
So you probably have
seen, it's pretty easy
to create any application
that is an Uber of something,
or a Spotify for something, or
"Clash of Clans" of something,
or [INAUDIBLE].
So what's going
to really, really
start setting people apart is
how they really, really think
about their brand.
What is the emotion?
What do I want my
product to stand for when
my users think of my product?
And that's what I
think it's going
to start happening next year.
You're going to see a
lot more talk about what
is that emotion that I want
to elicit from my user,
rather than, how do I get a
user to convert to being a paid?
KH: I totally agree
with branding.
So in Korea, CJ, which is one
of the top developers in Korea,
they already started branding.
I totally agree with that.
And then another thing
is that hardcore games,
it will be huge for
next year for sure.
But looking at
the casual titles,
we already saw that there
were many non-gamers starting
casual games after the
big boost of Kakao.
And then we figured out, those
casual titles are quite old.
So we might think that we can
see some new casual titles
coming next year.
So that'll be an interesting
point for next year in Korea.
YOSHI: So we don't
have that much time.
So in Japan, for the
games, probably we
will see more real time much
player games, playing together
with friends.
And in terms of
the non-game side,
we will see more tablet
and the material design,
optimized applications
for application side
in the Japan market.
LEON ZHAO: Thanks everyone.
So we're already
running out of time.
But as promised, I'll
take one live question.
[SPEAKING CHINESE]
AUDIENCE: [SPEAKING CHINESE]
LEON ZHAO: How important is it
to implement material design
games?
Does it matter?
Or do you see any games?
YOSHI: I don't
think the material
design is needed for the games.
game has its own game
world in the game.
So I think a more unique design
is needed in the game side.
Co-op quality guideline as well.
That's more like on
the application side.
But policy is important for
games and their applications.
No TPP.
LEON ZHAO: [SPEAKING CHINESE]